one of the guests you have coming is
Shinzo Abbi he's arriving at Matabele
stock there seems to be the beginnings
of a political deal if you like where
you might give up one of the kuril
islands in exchange for greater economic
cooperation are you open to a deal of
that sort
when you dare go in territory me Roger
problematic lishchyna we don't trade in
territories although the problem of the
peace treaty with Japan of course city
one and we would very much like to find
the solution to this problem with our
Japanese friends we had the treaty
signed in 1956 and surprisingly it was
ratified both by the Supreme Soviet of
the USSR and by the Japanese Parliament
and then the Japanese side refused to
adhere to it and then the Soviet Union
basically nullified all the agreements
with industry several years ago Japanese
colleagues asked us to return to a
discussion of this topic and we did that
we met them part way so in the past
couple years not by our initiative but
from the Japanese side these contacts
were frozen now our partners are showing
a willingness to return to a discussion
of this subject we're talking not about
some exchange or some sale we are
talking about finding a solution where
neither of the parties will feel
defeated us
ru is closer it was close to a deal now
as you have been since the 1960's is it
better now than any time since then yeah
I don't know what was the Navy Lee I
don't think it's closer than 1956 but in
any case we presumed to dialogue on this
subject and agree that our foreign
ministers and the chorus
joining experts at the deputy minister
level will step up their work of course
this will always be a topic of
discussion for the Russian president and
Prime Minister I'm sure that the name it
will mr. Abbey in Vladivostok will also
discuss this topic notice resolve it it
should be very well thought through
prepared and I repeat not on the
principle of damage limitation but
rather on the principle of setting the
stage for the development of
intergovernmental relations for the long
term